back in the Great Depression they
actually studied that makeup sales
didn't go down people were still willing
to spend money on makeup because they
wanted to look good they wanted to feel
good when I interviewed Patrick that
David in Miami recently I said what are
your tips going into a recession because
oh well for Content creators this is an
opportunity he's like some Industries
they might get crushed but content
creators it's the most recession-proof
business model when restaurants got shut
down during the lockdowns content
consumption went up when people are on
Hard Times viewing content goes up just
along with alcohol sales entertainment
actually does not go down are people
gonna still watch content the answers
yes